Musique
(Applaudissements)
Bonjour tout le monde. Je m'appelle Sirena.
J'ai 11 ans et je viens du Connecticut.
(Applaudissements)
Bon, je ne suis pas vraiment sûre de pourquoi je suis là.
(Rires)
Je veux dire, qu'est ce que cela a à voir avec
la technologie, le divertissement et le design?
Bon, je considère mon iPod, mon téléphone portable et mon ordinateur comme de la technologie
mais ça n'a rien à voir.
Alors, j'ai fait un peu de recherche dessus.
Bon, voici ce que j'ai trouvé.
Bien sûr, j'espère que je peux le mémoriser.
Le violon est basiquement fait d'une pièce en bois
et de quatre cordes principales.
En frottant les cordes, les cordes vibrent.
et produisent une onde sonore.
Le son passe à travers une pièce en bois appelé un chevalet
et descends dans la caisse de résonance qui l'amplifie
attendez ... laissez-moi réfléchir
(Rires)
Ok. D'autre part
en plaçant vos doigts en différentes positions sur le manche
ça change la longueur de la corde
qui change la fréquence de l'onde sonore.
Oh, mon dieu!
(Rires)
Ok. Cela ressemble à de la technologie
mais je la considère comme une technologie du 16e siècle
Mais en fait, la chose la plus fascinante que j'ai trouvée
était que le système audio
ou la transmission d'ondes de nos jours
sont toujours basés sur le même principe
de produire et projeter le son.
C'est pas cool?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Design -- J'adore son design.
Je me souviens quand j'étais petite
ma mère m'a demandé,
voudrais-tu jouer du violon ou du piano ?
J'ai regardé ce monstre géant
et me suis dit a moi-même --
Je ne vais pas rester attachée sur ce banc
toute la journée.
Ceci est petit et léger
Je peux en jouer debout, assise ou en marchant.
Et vous savez quoi?
Le meilleur de tout c'est que si je ne veux pas m'entraîner
Je peux le cacher.
(Rires)
Le violon est très beau.
Certaines personnes le comparent à la forme d'une femme
mais que vous le vouliez ou non
il existe depuis plus de 400 ans
à la différence de choses modernes qui paraissent obsolètes rapidement.
Mais je pense que c'est vraiment très personnel et unique que,
même si chaque violon se ressemble
que deux violons ne sonnent pas de la même façon.
Même s'ils sont du même fabricant
ou basés sur le même modèle.
Le divertissement -- J'adore le divertissement
mais en fait, l'instrument lui-même
n'est pas très divertissant.
Je veux dire, quand j'ai reçu mon violon pour la première fois
et essayé d'en jouer c'était
en fait, vraiment mauvais parce que
ça ne sonnait pas comme quand j'avais entendu d'autres enfants jouer
si horrible et grésillant
donc ce n'était pas divertissant du tout.
Mais sinon mon frère a trouvé ça très amusant.
Yuk, yuk, yuk.
(Rires)
Quelques années plus tard j'ai entendu une blague sur
le plus grand violoniste, Jascha Heifetz
Après le concert de M. Heifetz's
une dame est venue et l'a complimenté,
Oh, M. Heifetz, votre violon a sonné tellement bien ce soir.
Et M. Heifetz était une personne très cool
et donc il a pris son violon et a dit,
amusant, je n'entend rien.
(Rires)
Et maintenant, je réalise que comme musiciens
nous les êtres humains, nous avons un esprit formidable,
un coeur artistique et des compétences
qui peuvent changer la technologie du 16e siècle
et un design légendaire
en un magnifique divertissement
Maintenant, je sais pourquoi je suis là.
(Musique)
(Applaudissements)
Au début je pensais que j'allais être là seulement pour jouer
mais étonnamment, j'ai appris et apprécié beaucoup plus.
Mais ... cependant, certains d'entre eux me dépassaient complètement.
(Rires)
Comme le truc multidimensionnel.
Je veux dire, honnêtement, je serais déjà assez heureuse
si je pouvais faire juste mes deux dimensions à l'école.
(Rires)
Mais en fait, la chose la plus impressionnante pour moi
c'est que ... en fait,
J'aimerais aussi prendre position pour tous les enfants
c'est de dire, merci, à tout les adultes
pour être vraiment si attentionnés envers nous
et de faire de notre futur un monde meilleur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
(Musique)